the first thing that I want to do with
the concept is I want to know do you
want a lifestyle business or a
performance business right what are we
building so a lifestyle business is
going to be are we keeping it small so
that you can have fun freedom and
flexibility is that the purpose do you
want to just travel and work and have a
little gang of people that are you know
Rebels and misfits and we keep it small
and the whole purpose is fund Freedom
flexibility and especially we don't want
debt or investors right so that would be
a lifestyle business lifestyle Boutique
the second thing would be a performance
business which is we're building
something to sell it we want become big
and valuable we want to be 50 million
100 million plus in valuation we want 50
employees we're happy to take on
investors we want investors we want debt
we want to build something that's going
to be valuable so the first thing I'd
want to know is do you want a lifestyle
business or do you want a performance
business I think of it like a property
developer with a block of land do you
want to put your dream home on the block
of land or do you want to build a
10-story building and sell
it